here's the good news if somebody copies
you directly and is slightly better at
Tick Tock content than you and that was
what mattered you're not going to stop
them anyway what are you going to sit
and feel that's not gonna stop them you
can't stop winners so you gotta let
winners win too and you just got to
focus on being the best winner like when
Kobe was like working out at midnight it
wasn't like he was sending somebody to
like stop Iverson from working out he
could only focus on what he focused on
like when I think about the other young
business men and women that have come up
during my era I'm so happy because I
know a lot of them and a lot of them do
spend their time on the other
ones and I'm like oh he's fascinated by
like you won what are we spending 20
minutes of this dinner on a
third person that's also one like that's
a waste of time it's just bad energy
it's a complete waste of time